حتى المكتبه هنا في كابول لم تسلم طالما
ارتبط اسمها بالنساء فحرب طالبان على
المراه لم تتوقف بعد وتطال كل ما يتعلق
بها
في احدث فصول هذه الحرب اقدمت حركه طالبان
على اغلاق المكتبه النسائيه الوحيده في
العاصمه الافغانيه بعد سته اشهر فقط من
افتتاحها مسؤول المكتبه قالوا انهم
اغلقوها لاسباب امنيه وفرض قيود على
النساء من قبل حركه طالبان الى جانب تعرض
المكتبه للهجوم مرتين من قبل طالبان
لتنتهي القصه باغلاقها نهائيه اغلاق
المكتبه التي شكلت الملجا الوحيد للفتيات
في كابول يقابله اصرار من النساء على
افتتاح مكتبات سريه ردا على اقصاء طالبان
الممنهج له مع التوجه الحاد للحركه في
القضاء على حقوق المراه تتضائل الامال في
تاثير التحركات الدوليه للضغط على السلطه
حرمت النساء ليس من العمل والتعليم فقط بل
وحتى ارتياد المرافق العامه والترفيهيه
في اخر تحرك دولي تجاه ما تمارسه الحركه
فرض الاتحاد الاوروبي في الثامن من الشهر
الجاري عقوبات على وزير التعليم العالي في
طالبان نداء محمد نديم بسبب مسؤوليته عن
الانتهاك الواسع لحق المراه في التعليم
وزير اعلن علنا انه يريد قتل كل ما يخالفه